hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar a virtual conversation with dr
john moore
coveted vaccines and variants this
webinar is part of the coronavirus
virtual event series and i'm cindy
valdez of labyrinths and i will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinths so let's get started before
we begin i want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during this presentation to do so simply
type them into ask a question
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of this
presentation and if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
simply click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
now as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits
click on that click continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
hand corner of your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits
i now present today's speaker dr john
moore professor of microbiology and
immunology at whale cornell medicine for
a complete biography of our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
right hand side of your screen dr moore
welcome you may now begin
your presentation
well good afternoon everybody i think
the most important aspect of how this is
going to go is that i'll answer
questions because although i'll talk
about what i think is of current
interest
uh understanding
what interests you and what i can
hopefully help answer is is probably the
most productive way we're going to spend
time
well it's been an interesting year or an
interesting 18 months um my background
is in hiv vaccines and virology but
along with many of my colleagues we were
all forced last spring to
understand what was going on in the
pandemic and relate to coronaviruses as
a viral species and
also the vaccines that were developed
during um during 2020.
excuse me this time last year we were
all waiting for the first large-scale
results of the
phase 3 vaccine trials
and
every one of us was
pleasantly surprised by the efficacy of
the two mrna vaccines
none of us really saw coming
immunogenicity and efficacy data of the
magnitude that we saw in november
december of 2020 for vaccines to be
95 successful at preventing well the end
point in the trial was any form of
covert disease but
we also know they prevent infection
pretty well at least initially none of
us expected that we would have been
happy with 60 70 they were the kinds of
numbers we were floating around
we saw that as an amazing triumph for
the science and public health and
industry communities in developing
uh vaccines in the space of a year that
normally is a process that takes
multiple years nobody thought it would
be that quick
nobody thought it would be that good
so we have now three eua approved
vaccines in the states there are others
in europe asia south america other
countries but in the states we have
three vaccines
visa moderna the mrnas and much less
used for various reasons the johnson and
johnson and the virus vector
it's only used in about a tenth of the
number of people that the other two are
using so for all practical purposes
most americans are who've been
vaccinated received the mrnas which are
roughly equivalently potent and we can
discuss that
and are highly effective at preventing
infections and diseases at least they
were as soon after they were
approved
and yet the pandemic continues
again if you'd asked any of us
around the time that the vaccines were
rolled out at december of january of
this year to january 2021
we've said initially the problem is
rollout it's logistics it's getting
vaccines into arms it's getting enough
stocks produced it's enough stocks
delivered enough stocks administered but
once that happened
we really all truly thought
the pandemic would be curtailed this
summer
and by june or july there was enough
vaccine available in america
for the entire country to be vaccinated
and if that had happened
i think we'd be in a far happier place
and essentially the practice if the
practical aspects of the pandemic would
have been resolved but that's not what
we're seeing
and we see instead
75 to 100 million americans who have
refused to be vaccinated
and now we see a pandemic that is
concentrated among these unvaccinated
people
if you're in hospital and in the icu and
dying
it's about 20 fold more likely that
you're unvaccinated than vaccinated
vaccines are keeping people out of the
icu out of the morgue
and we have a disease pandemic
concentrated among people who have
chosen to refuse the vaccine
and as a consequence the pandemic
continues
i don't think any of us saw that coming
we were all aware
that there is
vaccine hesitancy anti-vaxxers movements
that
they were never going to get a hundred
percent vaccine uptake there are people
who refuse to take childhood vaccines
for their kids or a vaccine for
themselves they've always existed
but the influence of of q anon and party
politics and the crazy rumors that have
gone around and the amplification of
the few genuine side effect problems
that we've seen
that has had a dramatic impact on the
course of the pandemic and and i don't
think we anticipated that and i also
don't see a way that we can overcome
this
short of
mandates at a level that probably is
politically unacceptable we're seeing
more and more mandates imposed
most of us now in public health have
come to
think that that is a good idea again
at the start of this year pretty much
universally the reaction among vaccine
scientists and public health people and
virologists was that
we don't want bank mandates we don't
need mandates we don't think this is
going to happen general attitude has
changed dramatically over the past few
months because there is no alternative
way
to get more and more vaccine uptake and
hence get a control over the pandemic so
mandates for public health workers
mandates for people in contact with the
public
all of these are mondays for people
returning to in-person working all of
these are now being embraced by people
who initially oppose them again because
what choice do we have we're going to be
sitting here in a year's time having
another talk about the next variant if
we don't um
get more and more people
vaccinated and that's really very sad
and a reflection on american society
today that misinformation and
minimal truths and politicization
have uh taken over from science among
such a large section of the american
public it's it's a national tragedy it's
it's not unique to this country but it
does appear to be worse
because increasingly we are falling
further and further behind other
countries in the well in the western
world
in vaccine uptake among the population
and
yet we have more vaccine available here
in america than anywhere else
so it's it's essentially on us as a
society
variants are a thing
we again this time last year they were
not major issues on our radar screens
there was a variant that first arose uh
in the spring of 2020. the original
virus that spread from
wuhan
into asia into europe and from
principally from europe into america
there's a perception that the virus
entered america from china directly in
fact more cases originated from european
uh ski resorts and european
identifications and
uh european uh
business visitors then then came in from
the from china through the west coast
but the original what we call the wuhan
strain was rapidly replaced in the early
summer of 2020 by a variant that was
called d614g it never got a greek letter
but that
emerged in europe and
overtook
the original wuhan strain because it was
more transmissible it just
blew the wuhan strain away over a period
of months and became the dominant strain
worldwide it was not obviously more
pathogenic it was not antibody resistant
it didn't pose a threat to vaccines
and i think it lowered us into a sense
of complacency that well if that's the
worst you can throw at us coronavirus
bring it on you know it was a variant
we saw it coming we were not too
concerned about it
but then in
around october november of
2020 a new variant arose in britain that
was called b117 and we now call alpha
under the whose nomenclature it arose in
southeast england and very rapidly
overtook delta it was i'm sorry overtook
d1 d614g it very rapidly over uh became
the dominant strain in britain
and it did so because it is more
transmissible
it appeared to be uh require less of it
to infect a new person it was
so
it just spread more efficiently and a
virus that spreads more efficiently will
always out compete one that that spreads
less efficiently
um alpha
fortunately was not particularly
antibody resistant
so it was not again considered a threat
to vaccination programs
it is a bit more lethal
it did kill people in the hospitals it
could have higher viral loads in them
and that's not a good sign
and so it drove when then it spread into
europe and it spread into america and it
ceded the winter wave that we saw
in
uh the usa in the peak in mid-january
that was uh amplified alpha amplified
what was going to happen anyway
and the reason for the winter wave
last december january was twofold
increased travel
over thanksgiving
christmas new year
just spread the virus round in through
go through transportation through people
moving through people coming into
contact
and
again amplified by the transmissibility
of the alpha variant
so
and that was the worst uh
peak of the pandemic in the usa we had
up to 3 000 people a day dying in
mid-january
the vaccines then kicked in and
gradually had an impact uh during the
first months and blunted the pandemic
the alpha wave also diminished as we got
uh well for two reasons we think other
than vaccines for two reasons one it
scared people into
taking greater precautions that the
winter travel period was over
uh people became more and more aware of
the risk of the of the winter wave and
modified their behavior
and the weather eases and you know in
being indoors is a major driver of
spread and in the winter weather people
spend more time indoors
just just self-evident
so once we got into the spring the the
alpha wave
diminished
we started seeing um other variants
bounce around um beta which emerged in
south africa gamma which emerged in
brazil
were both
found in america along with something
that was called the california variant i
think it's finally called iota there was
a variant from new york i think it's
called kappa
these became a bit scarce story-ish
but they never really took off
and for peter and gamma that's actually
a good thing because they have
significant resistance to
vaccine and infection-induced antibodies
so we were all quite nervous about
beta and gamma in the early summer
because they could have been a threat on
some level
to
vaccine-induced immunity they probably
wouldn't have blown it away
but you couldn't discount the
possibility of a greater number of
vaccine breakthrough cases driven by
these antibody resistant variants
that's not what happened what instead
happened is the delta variant which
arose in india
in the early summer made its way
inevitably around the world including to
these shores and drove the delta wave
throughout the late summer period when
it's only now on the wave and delta is
even more transmissible than alpha
so alpha squelched out d614g and in turn
delta has squelched out alpha so the
american pandemic is presently delta
and it's spread like wildfire through
the south particularly because that's
where unvaccinated people were most
concentrated in red states with high
vaccine refusal content
and delta peaked in a couple of weeks
ago at killing 2000 people a day less
than alpha killed because
many people are protected against it by
vaccination
if it hadn't been for vaccination delta
would have triggered a death rate at
least two or three times as high uh
higher than it presently uh peaked out
at around 2000 a day i think we'd have
seen 5 000 people dying a day if um if
it hadn't been for the vaccines which
clearly in my view saved a massive
number of lives
delta is now
on the decline
the infection rates have halved over the
past two three weeks
and that's again typical of the pattern
that we've seen you get this wave a
spike up
a plateau and then it drops down
again
it's not absolutely clear what is
responsible for the decline and
one possibility is that
most vulnerable people have already been
found the virus has found the people who
are most susceptible in that population
so you burn through the most susceptible
and you finish up
running out of the easy targets
the second is again modification of
behavior people do go out and get
vaccinated or do
alter their behavior to protect
themselves in the face of death
um and the third is you know
just well the unknown i mean yeah i was
going to say that it's a change in the
weather but um that's actually acting in
the opposite direction so the fear we
have now is that there will be another
winter surge um again driven by holiday
travel and move indoors from uh you know
outside
outside events
it will be blunted in high vaccine
areas because the vaccines are doing
their job but again in the unvaccinated
regions
there could be another significant
winter surge we just hope not and but
that's you can't discount it
so that's my um
overview of where we are with vaccines
and where we are with variants
i expect we'll get a lot of questions
about boosters which has been the topic
du jour over the past month
well two months really
and um is the subject of ongoing fda
meetings this week so
i'll leave that topic and see what
questions arise which i'm sure will
include boosters but if there aren't any
questions about it i'll revisit it
so happy to take any questions at this
point
wonderful thank you dr moore for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the live q a portion of this
webinar if you have any questions you
want to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen
so let's get started
we have some great questions already
coming in from our audience members
our first question dr moore do we
anticipate any future mutations are
varying as virulent as
um
delta
will we see worse variants well nobody
can tell you that we won't i mean you
can't just sit here and say delta is the
worst it could possibly be
delta could for example acquire
the antibody resistance of
beta delta has a degree of antibody
resistance i mean it's more so than
alpha
but less so than beta
so but it doesn't seem to have enough
antibody resistance to blow past the
mrna vaccines
it would be troubling if delta acquired
the antibody resistance properties of
beta and retained its transmissibility
so that is a clear possibility but
doesn't mean to say it's going to happen
you could imagine an even more
transmissible variant than delta
none of these things is impossible but
there is a finite amount of mutations a
virus can accumulate without you know
running into diminishing returns
so again the more the virus spreads the
more people it replicates in
the more likely it is that we're going
to face a worse variant but you can't
give a probability to this it is clearly
a possibility
thank you so much now what are my
thoughts on the merck antiviral pills
well it's going to be controversial um
it doesn't seem to be that potent it's
going to have to be taken only in the
first few days after symptoms
which means that people have to
recognize that they need it it would
certainly be more convenient than
infusions of monoclonals
there's
been a story
right from when this drug was first
identified last year by a small biotech
company and then purchased by merck
there's been
stories in the scientific literature
about whether it's mutagenic or not
whether it can cause
damage to human dna
and there are conflicting reports on
this
but it's certainly out there
and it clearly also has to be something
then that the fda needs to seriously
look into because if it's out there
um then it's going to get amplified in
the you know q and on and crazy
facebook pages that this is a dangerous
drug i'm not saying it is a dangerous
drug i don't know
the truth of whether the mutagenesis
story is going to pan out or not you can
argue that a company as large as merck
would not have taken on a drug like this
without doing due diligence and being
satisfied that it was appropriate but
that's what we have an fda for so we'll
let's have to let's wait and see what
the fda reviewers decide on on this
aspect of its
alleged properties
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in dr moore what
percentage of those who have received
the mrna vaccines
are seeing heart problems particularly
myocarditis
very very low
um concentrated uh among young men as an
israeli study
about a week ago that had the most
detailed numbers in it you know i can't
remember the exact numbers it was
something like 130 cases reported
out of um
many tens of millions of vaccine
recipients in israel who received the
fisa vaccine so it was 129 out of a i
think five million um maybe even more
than five million so you know that's a
low incidence and i think of those cases
uh all but about four or five were mild
and didn't require hospitalization or at
least not to any significant extent
um
they arose as i said in predominantly in
16 to 19 year old men there were almost
no women there were almost no
older men
and
um
they arose typically within three or
four days of vaccination it wasn't a
delayed side effect
so
look all medical interventions have some
side effects i mean aspirin uh some
people can't take aspirin because it
gives them a stomach upset um i crunch
for stuff i mean we have to accept that
there is always a risk
to all medical interventions and you
have to balance the risk to the benefit
covid also causes myocarditis and there
are far more myocarditis cases in
infected people than in vaccine
recipients so you have to balance the
risk of getting infection and
myocarditis against the very low risk of
an mrna causing that side effect and if
you're a woman or an older man i
essentially negligible risk at all
thank you so much we have quite a few
questions coming in about children and
vaccines this first question is from a
concerned parent and she asks
considering the vaccine is so new what
is your view on the discussion on
children's vaccines already
well again the fda has to finish doing
its its job and is
is reviewing information i am personally
in favor of vaccinating kids
my own children are adults i'm old
but if i had young children of school
age i'd want them vaccinated again
because the although covid doesn't kill
that many kids it does kill some
and it causes this horrible complication
called miss c
kind of jargon term but there are
serious uh side effects long-standing
and serious in sufficient children to
know that there's a definite
demonstrable measurable risk to getting
covered
and i would want to eliminate that risk
from my children and i
again
the data that has been publicly released
on the safety of vaccines and children
doesn't raise any concerns in my eyes
that would affect my decision to
vaccinate my children if they were of
that age
so i i think it's it makes sense
to protect the kids
and protect
the people that the children come into
contact with
which includes other children
teachers
parents if they're not vaccinated
grandparents older adults
it's a societal
issue vaccines don't just protect people
they protect society and the last thing
we need is kids to be another reservoir
of virus transmission
that keeps the pandemic going so i think
the risk benefit ratio based on what
i've seen so far is clearly in favor of
vaccinating children
thank you dr moore and along with this
line what are the thoughts
what are your thoughts about the
mandates for vaccinations for children
about five to eleven this seems very
controversial right now with parents
threatening to pull their children from
school or leaving school districts that
plan to abide by these mandates what are
your thoughts i have not seen any
mandate for vaccinating children i've
seen mask mandates which i think make a
great deal of sense but i have not seen
uh any well the vaccines aren't
authorized for children of five to
eleven so i mean you can't mandate
something that's not authorized yet so i
i don't know where that story originates
um
childhood vaccination is mandated for
schools in general i mean you can't send
in most parts of the country including
in republican controlled states you
can't send your kids to school
without the standard array of childhood
vaccinations and for most parents that's
not controversial i mean mmr
uh just the standard childhood array of
vaccines i
because my kids are not school age i've
lost track of exactly how many
but we had to have them done uh to send
them to school in new york city and and
that's standard nationwide it's just
accepted
that childhood vaccinations are an
appropriate thing to do to protect
children against um
nasty infections we we do this and it's
for 90 95 percent of american parents
that is not an issue there's always an
anti-vaccine movement that has withstood
that for reasons that i personally don't
accept that we know it exists
so i just don't see a difference i think
if a vaccine came in for children
that protected them and the people in
contact with them it should be used
whether any local or national authority
would mandate vaccines for children i do
not know i can't speak about it but i
have not seen that as a proposal
thank you so much
and what are your thoughts on the
portion of the public who are afraid to
have the vaccine due to past vaccines
found to cause serious side effects
years after the fact for example
children ending up with down syndrome or
women ending up with infertility issues
well these are internet myths i mean
they don't exist i mean there is no the
vaccine the the covered vaccines do not
cause women to have infertility issues
you know the the stuff that goes around
on the internet is that vaccinated
people transmit death rays
via 5g networks that affect people who
come into contact with them i mean
that's just nonsense there's no there is
zero science behind that i mean that's a
you know a q a on inspired rumor
vaccines do not cause these fertility
problems and there was a recent report
um that pregnant women
uh who get covered are not having good
outcomes that it's causing them real
problems over and above what would
happen uh for the same age group of
non-pregnant women
so
that they've been reluctant to be
vaccinated some of them because of the
fear that there is something problematic
for their developing children there is
no evidence that that is true but
getting covered while you're pregnant is
gonna have an impact on both the woman
and quite conceivably on the developing
child
so yeah we've got uh
rumors and myths that need to be
curtailed because they are driving this
vaccine reluctance and there's no
scientific basis for any of it
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience this is a great q a
our next question
how long will the two or three vaccine
shots last and will there be an annual
booster shot
well this is the booster debate and you
know i knew it would come up so let's
talk about it um
over the
summer
fisa ceo started going on you know tv
newspapers basically saying my company's
product isn't working very well which
kind of surprised a lot of us who've
interacted with the pharmaceutical
industry over the years you don't tend
to get
companies um
saying my product doesn't work very well
and then saying oh but you need more of
it so there was a bit of skepticism
about this as to how
necessary
a
vaccine shot actual third vaccine shot
actually is
but there's a lot of people in america
just there are people who refuse to take
vaccines there are people in america who
have really really embraced vaccines
and therefore
um are desperate to get as many as they
possibly can i mean there's the worried
well who have convinced themselves that
they are
um
losing their immunity to vaccines and
want another dose so
you know give me another dose this week
and another one the week after i mean
exaggerating but there are people who
are very very eager to get their third
dose and many of them found a way to do
this just by you know going into your
local vaccine provider and
telling them the story i mean you can
gain the system you could get it
so a lot of people got their third doses
now a couple of weeks ago um fda and cdc
after a fairly tortuous process
signed off on a third vaccine dose
for many americans who'd received two
pfizer doses so it's authorized for fisa
recipients this week we've got fda and
cdc meetings this week and next
on jnj do they get authorized the second
dose and moderna do they need a third
dose so that's all ongoing and i having
done a recommendation as there's a
recommendation for pfizer to me it's
inconceivable same recommendations won't
happen for moderna and jnj
uh
you just would get really into anarchy
if you said this vaccine needs it but
these don't so i think by in the next
few months
um essentially every american who wants
a third dose or in the case of j and j a
second dose is going to get it
at the moment it's being done on a you
have to wait six months after your
second
fiver dose before you're eligible
although again people are gaming the
system somewhat
and that makes sense immunologically you
don't want to get a third dose too soon
after your second that just doesn't make
a lot of sense immunologically so you
have to you should wait a significant
period of time
um
it's
mostly it's being done in the order if
you remember go back to december and
january of 2020 2021
the vaccines were initially given in a
staggered rollout so that older most
vulnerable people and healthcare workers
got them first and then they moved down
to 60 year olds and 50 year olds et
cetera et cetera we all remember the
process well that's what's happening
with the fisa boosters they're being
prioritized initially
for people in the most vulnerable groups
older people etc who got their vaccines
longer period of time
but if you're a you know 20 year old and
got your um vaccine in july you don't
need a booster at this point um and it
you wouldn't be able to get one unless
you gain the system and i don't
recommend that
so yeah by the end of the year
essentially all americans
who want a third shot or a second j j
shot are going to have it
and most will
most people who've been vaccinated have
embraced vaccines
that's what i think will happen
thank you so much dr moore now we also
have quite a few questions about annual
shots will you
will you do you think that we will
eventually need annual covid 19 shots
similarly to the annual flu shot and the
second part of that
um
maybe do you believe instead it'll be a
kobe 19 booster shot as being part of
that annual shot
well there's some terminology issues
here i mean when is a booster at the
dose when is a booster an annual dose
i think some of this is just going to
have to play out
it depends on a couple of things i mean
one
what is the
longevity of the immune response and
it's not just antibody response it's
immune memory and we understand a lot
more about immune memory now to the to
the vaccines
so what is the status of our immune
memory and immunological response
to these vaccines in a year's time i
mean if we're talking about and we're
going to get i think an annual we're
going to get a shot a third shot
this year so let's not talk about this
year that's that's what we're calling
dose three
will we need one
in a year's time this time in 2022 well
let's look at
the immune response in vaccine
recipients
next summer let's judge it also
what's the state of the circulating
virus if we finally control this
pandemic
and
covid becomes a
low grade
infection
that is
hitting
you know a few
hundred or a few thousand people a day
it may not justify an additional
roll-out
um
so again we have to wait and see what
the future brings i mean we don't have
crystal balls it's it's second guessing
a lot of these things is it's just
beyond our you know beyond our
capabilities we have to look at the data
at the time decisions would need to be
taken but you know all of these issues
pale against the importance
of getting
doses one and two
into more and more people because again
i'll just repeat myself it is a pandemic
of the unvaccinated
and the unvaccinated are people now
responsible for fueling this pandemic
for keeping it going
if we could only persuade the vaccine
refuses to be vaccinated by whatever
means possible
then
we may not need an annual dose because
we could control a pandemic that's
what's so frustrating about all of this
now now to all of us
thank you so much and yes and
can can current covet 19 tests
tell me whether i am infected with a
virus variant like delta or how do
people know if they have the alpha
variant versus one of the variants of
the virus
you can't do this on an over-the-counter
basis uh if you're
in a member of a hospital study cohort
then you can i mean
you know if i were infected uh which is
unlikely
uh a sample from me would go to a
hospital lab and they could tell me what
what i got although i may not be
entitled to the information it's part of
a study goal um so yes the methodology
exists but it's not particularly
valuable to the public
um
plus
essentially
every infection in the states at the
moment is delta i mean 90 x percent i
mean it's overwhelmingly likely that
you've got delta if you've become
infected
and the extra information
you know it has no value it doesn't
change how you would be treated um or
should respond
so
yeah
anyway you can't just go to you know
your local drug store and say give me a
delphi test because they don't exist the
methodology is pretty specialized and
involves you know machinery that is
typically found in research labs
thank you so much and again great
questions coming in
dr moore what could be done to curb the
social media or media in general the
spread of misinformation these myths
conspiracy theories about covid19 and
vaccines like the one you brought up
earlier
are there better ways to educate people
and provide credible sources of
information
well that's what we all try and do
i spend a lot of my time talking to
journalists and science writers and
trying to help them write accurate
stories
so there's a ton of really good accurate
information around
but if you're in uh you know a fox news
mindset you don't read the washington
post the new york times cnn the atlantic
you know sources of what i consider to
be reliable information if you're
getting your information on your
granny's facebook feed and she says i've
just read this
stuff you should read it too what can
you do about it i mean you know shutting
social media down would be would be
wonderful in my view but it's not going
to happen
um and you know facebook and youtube try
to manage the kind of nonsense that
circulates but it's an uphill battle
um so it's where do people get their
information it's not that there's a
dearth of in a dearth of accurate
information there's a ton of accurate
information but you have to be willing
to read it and accept that it is
accurate information and you know i've
interacted with vaccine refusing people
and they simply reject the premise that
information in you know the new york
times is accurate because they think
it's fake news
so it again speaks to the politicization
they believe what they hear from their
friends
uh from republican leaders in some cases
because this is polarized i mean you get
very few demo well all the democrat
political leaders have embraced vaccines
but about a third of republican
congressmen have refused to be
vaccinated for exactly that reason
so you you believe what you hear and
people's information sources now
incredibly polarized um i i we saw
you know we saw disinformation i told
you at the start that my background is
hiv aids
and
uh in the 15 years ago i was in a group
that battled a group of what we call the
aids denialists people who do not
believe that hiv caused aids and that
hiv was caused by you know drug abuse
and all sorts of nonsense and that that
kind of myth killed hundreds of
thousands of people in south africa for
instance and you know we fought that
online and you can do it
but now it's just amplified out of all
proportion i mean it's just a massive
expansion of of garbage information on
social media but it's still the same
same people who is responsible for this
kind of information an awful lot of it
is driven by people with a financial
stake in disinformation
so if you want to
increase the sales of your herbal remedy
or your colloidal silver or whatever the
crazy stuff du jour is you're running a
alternative medicine website for profit
you steer people towards it and you
steer people away from vaccination your
financial interests
are to stop people getting vaccinated
and steer them towards the kind of
nonsense that you sell them
and you know alex jones who's one of the
prime portrayers um on the internet or
by talk radio you know his website is
full of
um
adverts for stuff that he sells they
won't do you any good but will make him
a
there are others there are others like
this you know the leaders in the
anti-vaccine movement
have very significant back
financial stakes
in trashing vaccination
and trashing drugs that work and
steering people to ivamectin and hydroxy
you know either mectin and
hydroxychloroquine have been embraced by
the right
and there's no basis for it there's no
scientific basis for either drug i mean
yet people choose to prefer
to take a drug that is used for
deworming cattle and sheep and horses
and eat it
on the basis of no fda approved data
whatsoever they reject the premise that
the fda is here to
check drug safety
it's just an alternate universe
thank you so much for that answer
and dr moore are there any fears that
variant would mutate against the vaccine
antibodies resulting in a more
contagious or potentially lethal virus
and do you think any we will see any
other major variants similar to delta
well i kind of just you know answered
that at least part of it and say you
can't say we can't you can't say there
won't be a worse variant because there
could be there's no evidence that
vaccination is driving variance
if you get infected after vaccination
you suppress you have lower viremia
after a couple of days so that's why you
don't get sick if you get infected after
vaccination you almost always have mild
disease at most because the virus the
fact
the the vaccine-induced immune response
controls the extent of virus replication
in your body
and the less virus replication the less
likely you are to develop a variant
where variants seem to have arisen is in
people who have immunosuppressed
conditions people whose um
you know innate health
uh whether it's cancer driven
some immunosuppressed other impressive
conditions immunosuppressive conditions
means that they don't develop immune
responses well
um so these poor and these unfortunate
people
don't control the virus when they get
infected and they can be
have be highly viremic
for you know a month or two months they
don't their immune response doesn't kick
in
uh in some nowadays they can be treated
with monoclonal antibodies and that will
help them there's enough examples of
that
but people who who are immunosuppressed
and have had virus replicating them in
them for a long period of time
that is a scenario in which variants
have emerged
and that's the principal driver if
vaccines act the opposite way they
suppress virus replication in people
thank you so much
our next question the fact that the
vaccines were fast-tracked approved
there are concerns about long-term side
effects what are the anticipated
long-term side effects of vaccinations
for kova 19
well they were fast track approved
because we were in the middle of a
pandemic
what was the alternative uh take a you
know one to two year approval process
and keep our fingers crossed i mean
it was necessary to put them through an
emergency use authorization procedure
but that doesn't mean to say that no
data were generated and reviewed the fda
did a thorough job that was open to the
public and we could see it happen you
could log on to all of these
advisory committee meetings and see the
sausage being made and you know that's
part of the public confidence
look it's technically impossible
to eliminate
the scenario in which there is a side
effect that emerges after a year or two
years because you could only see it
after a year or two years by definition
we can only go
we can't shoot forward in time
but vaccine side effects
when they occur
almost invariably
are seen within days to weeks
of vaccination
they don't take place over very long
periods of time so this is one of those
things that people seem to think is
likely but the professionals in the
field go that is incredibly unlikely
so i
you know my family had four different
vaccines um
my um
my my daughter got uh
pfizer my wife got madonna my son got j
j and i was an experimental vaccine
trial of a vaccine called novabax it's
not approved
and i never had a moment sleep loss over
the consequences
for my family of being vaccinated
as to what might happen multi years down
the road i just don't think that's a
risk that exists and it's not something
i sweat over in the slightest
now has there been any data on how the
new delta variant impacts unvaccinated
children
well doubtful is more transmissible
and if so
the kids are more at risk of acquiring
delta
than they would have been before delta
emerged i mean that's the nature of that
variant it it just spreads more rapidly
so it gets in a classroom it will go
around the classroom
um
and the more people the more kids it
infects the more kids will have serious
consequences whether miss c or in some
cases about death
and there are there are you know there's
not a lot of data on this it's very
sometimes you know people if you think
data can be just generated you know by
snapping your fingers and it comes out
of um
out of thin air it actually takes a lot
of time and effort and study
to to analyze what's going on so we
don't have a really definitive story
about whether delta is more dangerous in
kids that it infects or is more
transmissible to kids
it's it's probably a bit of both it's
it's definitely more transmissible and
it's probably
a bit more dangerous than the variants
that were around last year were but it's
certainly not something to take lightly
you wouldn't want to get it
dr mark is there any testing options out
there to reflect viral loads in
individual testing and instead of
positive or negative actually showing
how long or how high your viral load is
again not over the counter
viral load assays yeah they clearly
exist and they're used to generate
information that goes into scientific
publications because they're done in
specialized laboratories
uh
would that be valuable to the public i'm
not sure i i don't
you got to look at your own symptoms i
mean if you vaccinated the probability
is you're going to have mild symptoms if
you get infected at all and don't get
don't get me wrong the vaccines prevent
most infections but if you do get
infected
many of those infections are
asymptomatic
and the ones that
more typical are mild infections you've
got to follow your own symptoms i'm not
sure that a number will really help you
i mean you've got to be able to
interpret the number
i mean numbers are typically viral loads
are expressed in what's called ct values
if somebody told you that your ct value
was 25 would that tell you something
useful you'd have to have a fair amount
of medical knowledge
to be able to interpret it in fact
something a ct value of 20 is probably
bad news and the ct value of 30 is
insignificant
so i i know that um but i if i'd be if i
had symptoms of infection i wouldn't be
going out there and trying to find out
what my viral load is because i don't
think i'd find it helpful
thank you so much we have time for a few
more questions dr mora we have some
questions coming in about other
countries the first one is
how does the u.s vaccine compare to
other vaccines in other countries
depends on the vaccine um i mean pfizer
and modern are
pfizer in particular was rolled out very
early in europe um pfizer and moderna
are used a lot um the astrazeneca
vaccine that was never approved in
america and it's on a par with j and j
but you know
it's certainly no better than j j it's
never approved in america so it's a moot
point here that was developed in the uk
it's used widely in the uk
along with pfizer
it was also used widely in europe but
it's mostly replaced by the mrnas
part of that is you know brexit
anti-british
european politics and safety concerns
um
but it is used so astrazeneca is a thing
abroad the chinese have been very
aggressive at marketing some pretty
cruddy vaccines um
inactivated virus vaccines of an old
determine an old technology that we will
never see here
there are three or four of them um
quite widely used in in the far east
inevitably uh in south america they are
okay they will keep people from dying
most of the time certainly i'm not
saying they're useless but they're
nowhere near as good as the
vaccines we use here
the russians have um a vaccine called
sputnik fee that they've also been been
marketing in eastern europe some other
countries from african countries
it's uh it's quite similar to
astrazeneca and jnj in design may
actually actually be better than both of
those
vaccines you know if you believe
everything the russians publish sputnik
v is not bad vaccine but you'll never
see it in america
so these are all vaccines that are used
in different countries
different countries don't always
recognize vaccine status
uh that's been a you know people a big
deal for people wanting to travel
between countries you know i got the
russian vaccine will you let me into
your country no go away you know that
kind of bureaucracy definitely exists
um but of course the big picture in the
globe is that there is not enough
vaccine to immunize the planet and it's
incredibly important we do so because
until we
protect the planet
the virus will still circulate and it
will come back at some point variants
can arise abroad you know you can't
build a wall around america and keep a
respiratory virus out nor should we
so it's imperative morally and also for
the nation's best interests to support
vaccination programs globally
thank you so much and can you comment on
sweden's decision to applaud the use of
the modern vaccine can you comment on
this and if we anticipate other
countries falling due to the hard risk
of younger people
well as i said earlier i mean
the risk is is pretty small um
you know
and and it's surprising
that the same information hasn't been
seen with fisa given the similarities so
i think we need more more more
information on this i mean it is
certainly possible that cdc might change
the restrictions and say to
young men in
16 to 20 age range which are the
dominant risk group
to get a different vaccine that's
possible
um
but you know where's the data i mean
there's another one of these frustrating
scenarios where
a couple of scandinavian countries made
a decision
announced it in the press the american
press picks it up none of us seen the
data it's based on
they say well we're going to file it
with the european you know equivalent of
the fda and well sure but i mean you
can't make a decision based on data you
haven't seen i mean it's a frustrating
scenario
so
i don't know we have to wait and see
what what data would justify a change in
american policy
thank you so much
we have time for one more question
the us
is sharing millions of vaccinations with
other countries how do we get this virus
eradicated and under control globally
well again what i just said the more
the more the virus circulates the longer
the pandemic will continue the more risk
of additional variants emerging in some
country or other and spreading to
america
the more there'll be economic disruption
the more there are travel restrictions
the less likely it is we can return to a
normal pre-pandemic life
so it's in everyone's interest
to help completely curtail this pandemic
which requires global vaccination
programs and it's always the less
developed less economically
wealthy countries that suffer the worst
in this kind of setting they don't have
the financial clout that the us
government have or european governments
do
so you know i think there's a a moral
but also public health imperative to
help the entire human race overcome this
pandemic virus because it won't just go
away
absolutely dr morris thank you very much
for your presentation today and for
participating
would you like to provide any closing
remarks before we go
encourage everyone you know who hasn't
been vaccinated to go and get accurate
information get off facebook get onto
sites that you know most of us medical
professionals would consider reliable go
and
go and read other information and don't
consider it fake news i mean if we all
convert one hesitant person
you know it makes a difference but
without that
we can have the same conversation in a
year's time hello what's the state of
the pandemic in late 2022 i don't want
to have that conversation it's you know
it becomes tedious we all want to get
our lives back to normal and right now
the unvaccinated is what is preventing
american life returning to pre-pandemic
norms
so the more effort we can all put in to
change that the better
absolutely thank you again dr moore for
your time today before we go i want to
thank our audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand for two
years since october 2023 lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time take care everyone be safe
bye-bye